greetings and salutations welcome two
things you missed right here on gamespot
we are kind of funnies Colin Moriarty
and Tim Geddes and Tim no they were here
to talk about something you and I are
both very excited about although I'm a
little worn by a little more I meet a
lot more skeptical of it than you are
I'm vinyl Cosby I've been dreaming I
appreciate that we always are and I'm
always back off man yin and yang yeah so
I PSX we saw something unexpected I'm
think anyone expected to see this not
only in an expanded trailer but a bunch
of in-game footage of what they're
working on showing some of the early
portions of the game particularly the
bombing of the mako reactor exactly so
let's talk about so this is the bombing
mission a final fantasy 7 everything
from the trailers from the very early
moments of that game which I'm really
excited about because we kind of get to
see it from a whole new whole new look a
couple interesting things to me is this
is using the Unreal for it now an unreal
engine for me which I find really kind
of weird because originally we saw the
agni's philosophy uh trailer e3 2012
they kind of showed off this square
luminous engine yeah something
proprietary yes right so nothing we know
about this is that it's being made by a
cyber connect yeah it's so this is where
things get a little unclear because it
seems like it's going to be a
collaboration between Square Enix
obviously probably on the production
side and cyber connect and perhaps other
studio cyber connect best known for the
very popular JRPG series dot hack on ps2
they do a lot of the Naruto games
they've done a lot of stuff negative
serves wrath um so they've been around
the block in there a good developer it's
unclear how much of the load they're
taking on what I assume is it's similar
to the games that Santa Monica puts out
at Sony where they're producing it
someone else entirely yes cyber connect
see this seems to be a cyber connect
project exactly now here's the thing on
this is the first time we've seen game
playing from the remake and it is the
the first one we really really kind of
seen an extended look at the game
because the first trailer was kind of
like height that fans upon tyne c7 new
was found pasty 7 but it wasn't very
clear until the very end when you see
the cloud reveal you know unless you're
like fighting insurance and stuff like
that this trailer its final fantasy 7
through and through including the typos
and weird translation stuff the
legendary becomes real you don't think
you don't think that that makes sense
that seems to make sense to me really
yeah the legendary like the legendary
become becomes real it's either the
legendary become real or the legends
become real the legendary becomes real I
the way this is a classic story about
baggage right thing by the grammar if
it's led if legendary is indicated
because legend air can be plural or
singular so I think they mean it as
plural right the legendary know they
were meaning a singular the legendary
becomes real god this is going on I
don't know but he talked about how i
journeyed some stretch I was kind of
making a joke that this is the vile
fancy through and through because this
is weird I find it weird ah but here we
instantly see some stuff that I got this
river I never thought we would see hmm
which is our girl Jessie it's chilling
there yeah it's cool like where it's
cool to see proper representations of
characters that were that played
important roles in an avalanche or in
just in general in that really kind of
Midgar section of the game it was very
dark and very dire and seems to be
captured pretty well in the aesthetic of
this see Jesse Biggs wedge and all of
them it's very cool it's very very cool
and I like that these trailers are just
showing a sephiroth antifa and all that
stuff it's like I cool it's actually
let's get into what the game was right
you know yeah they are showing my
assumption is they're showing what they
have you know definitely definitely um
so what's interesting to me here is if
you there's a bunch of little flashes
and stuff right this is awesome this is
me midgar yeah and the reactors uh and
again capturing the essence of this dark
ready disgusting City yeah and this is
this is what we saw when the game was
revealed so we do see little clips of
parts of the game that we saw when the
game was revealed them walking with shoe
width and when it's revealed at his
cloudbuster sure um we've seen before I
like how they that stitch that in as
well what's awesome is you see these
even just it's a staircase and it's like
I i can see that staircase in my head of
plymouth NC 17 that is the bombing
mission beginning and it's like they're
nailing it from you and so far i'm
loving this so going through a bit more
this big kind of a sort of quick retread
of their the first trailer we saw then
we get into going back to
the the opening of the original final
fantasy 7 & Co know if you saw the
amazing graphic comparison the game spot
put up I know when it first came out
where its side by side comparisons it is
it's like a literal translation turtle
Jessi combs and kicks and it's like it's
just like this and it's awesome and then
Barrett pretty much redesigned here
totally design it you know the original
game you looked a bit more at least in
that the art was more than mr. t ya feel
llegue just look like a bunch of shapes
together right now yeah I mean it just a
bunch of polygons uh be as sweet arm
tattoos is oakleys as people been
talking about not crazy about this
design for but I don't know exactly like
he is embarrassed in such a character of
the 90s that it's hard like what are you
really going to do with it but I mean I
kind of like that though I mean he very
much looks like blade right sure and
what's it I like the fact that he looked
like mr. t back in the nineties when he
was supposed to represent the kind of
older thing now he looks more 90 right
yeah I think it's kind of cool and I
don't know if they did that on purpose
but I think they did and he's saying all
these lines that there's actual text
straight from the game so you now you
can hear what we read all those years
yeah that's very cool the aesthetic they
nail the way the game works now right
here we see the first boss guard
scorpion but what I love is these subtle
little things the way that the camera
swings around them is the way the camera
would swing around them in the battle
right like whales right here I don't
care I love it it's just a nice little
throwback right um do they are getting
ready to fight his swords or guns a lot
longer here we're seeing some traversal
which is cool yeah so these are scenes
from like that that happened in followed
a c7 we didn't actually get to plane we
just kind of see an explosion and then
cloud can went through it and Here I
mean you know square now it has tomb
Raider's this is very modern tomb raider
asked not to say that that's its ripped
straight out of it but like this does
remind me of like rise of the gym yeah I
mean this is more indicative to me the
it's not even an action role-playing
game feel although it is it's just the
way games look now so it's it's cool to
be able to use a little bit of lessee
your imagination although I think that
was one of the fun things about final
phase said was having to use your
imagination these are so blocking plug
it on so primitive but now we get really
these beautiful these beautiful scenes
and again just the darkness and the
greenness in the 30s
I know so weird they were like look at
all the like the crap on the ground like
all the litter and everything it's just
it's a it's populated you saw that
earlier when they're walking through
Midgard the marketplace there's people
like it's it's a city that's alive and
again what's crazy is this is ripped
straight out of the first game like you
see the the pre-rendered backgrounds
these houses are their piece this
staircase you go up and down it's really
crazy I'm and that that little glare
coming off the sword you see it the
lighting engine is really nice yeah the
Lighting's nice everything's
everything's looking great aesthetically
and I'm I'm interested the way the game
plays maybe a little bit different but
the way the game looks yeah cloud looks
a little scrawny to me so here's my
thing that's a lot of people are saying
that the thing about dark cloud we gotta
Steve Burton voicing him just like he
has an epic children kingdom hearts and
all this up for four years at this point
um we'll see if they they kind of go the
more haven't children out or the classic
phone fancier I'm really hoping that
they stick to seven this trailer seems
to kind of show that him being all
scrawny and looking a little sickly and
stuff I mean we need to remember at this
point he's being affected heavily by the
mako energy and all that stuff so it's
like I think that that is a design
choice that they made I also think he
just looks skinnier a because of his big
shoulder guard which is there we're
gonna see any we see that and not
politically and a sword is madison new
so if there's gonna be some
discrepancies I do like that it's very
much the original designs they're not
going to have been children look with a
bunch of belts and stuff and even I with
better going back and kind of like
redesigning everything that's good
because it would have been easy for them
it just kind of give that look in cover
today also the music that's playing
right now the original bombing mission
saw but it's the it's important to note
that it wasn't orchestrated just for
this trailer that is from an orchestral
CD called distant distant worlds that
came out years ago so it is a
pre-existing track nice lots fine if it
works it works not everything needs to
be redesigned
no my point there is that it's not like
we're that far along the development oh
you think they will grow back in as well
yeah I think third day I'm they're gonna
have we're definitely not far oh yeah
yeah and then uh any other boy that's
wedge right that is wedge yes but one of
my biggest uh greetings to this trailer
is his voice is weird think he's a
little too squeaky I just love that
Biggs and wedge have been a file fans
nutrition for a very long time yeah
characters in every game that they
appear in essential parts in this game
just like in Final Fantasy 6 with the
magitek armor they play an important
role he get the early game too and we're
going forward here a bit about to come
off on the air at the gameplay soon
which was a huge would be like no one
thought we were gonna see this for a
long time seriously he starts getting
affected in those like visions and [ __ ]
that he was getting yeah so here's where
things get interesting and it's just
it's my like who knows so we see if you
think we see a limit break the let me
break meter in the bottom right glad
HTTP suggest really sure amar I don't
know there was something I think the
more Arkansas say said about that barn
turning red and paying attention to that
bar not entirely sure it seemed also
like I'm reading Agra mat-su piece about
from it sooo are translated from limit
to where a lot of the design aesthetic
in terms of the gameplay is not even
done know me I'm very obvious clue the
back to that is the fact if you look
over the the bottom left of the screen
you see the kind of options in his
attack Magic summon items defend now
that's what found a c7 hat minus the
defend and the fact that summon is here
means that this is just here for demo
purposes like you could you know get
someone's to way later in the game so it
wouldn't be there um in that this
portion again you can press over and get
defend right it wasn't in the mood was
yeah exactly and then don't mean the
other red herring here is that he has
two thousand hit points um yeah which
wouldn't be happening until midway
through them so or maybe not quite many
way to the game baby a little bit later
yeah so we start off there with that
what I think is cool is that so defend
does say that there it they're thinking
about this Val system is different it's
not gonna be like something we've seen
before a lot of people are saying oh
it's fun fancy 15 it's not this is very
different than that there is at least a
menu to go through um it looks kind
similar to me more of a kingdom hearts
kind of the kingdom hearts birth by
sleep where the red bar kind of goes up
you can do stronger moves right stuff
like that um but again it's unique this
is a new battle system and I'm
interested in it just because it looks
more active than a lot of final
fantasies so far they've been kind of
like it's still kind of wait your turn
this looks like that bar is more of a
combo meter where you just cant span
things over and over though well here's
what can toss a says about the battle
system this is from komatsu via
automatic translation this quote rather
than a command battle ensuing where you
would counter an enemy we're aiming for
a seamless active battle as you can see
in the trailer so that's what we're
seeing here then Nomura says quote
regarding the battle speed and tempo for
the sake of a stress-free battle we want
to do something on the level of the city
of final fantasy as far as the degree of
action goes it's dissidia final fantasy
than kingdom hearts then Final Fantasy 7
remake yeah there won't be any action
that requires a technique by using the
new system we want to act we want to do
action battles while also being able to
fight thinking strategically yeah and
then they ask about elements of the
original battle system in tomorrow says
quote in the end it's based on Final
Fantasy 7 so elements like the ATV gauge
which is really important an active Time
battle and limit breaks which we see
here at least in the corner will appear
with new ways to be used please look
forward to how this game will follow
through well I mean another obvious vibe
I'm getting this crisis core absolutely
it's the battle system it's very
different than a tighter than Christ at
least in terms of the you have to wait
the turn and you can attack with the
turn and you can tack so that's cool and
another huge reveal here that people are
wondering about you can play as Barrett
right so you can switch I think you can
toggle with the triggers between the
character so you can stay as one you'll
always have three characters just like a
597 with you can party and they'll fight
via a I unless you want to control them
so you could conceivably control class
which iving Tran another thing
throughout this trailers the particle
effects are super awesome every attack
has like lightning and then little like
flashes and stuff going and it looks
really nice here we got clouds first let
me break braver just look at that again
who's awesome at baratz first limit
break big shot
not sure what that is but it looks cool
this again again all in engine yeah so
it's in it is very seamless there's no
that we got cut / what looks to be cross
laughs yeah so again way ahead of
ourselves in terms we are to have for
sure well I it's funny can we don't see
it here I mean is it often train
sequence in their genius game um just
want to see the menus yeah I donate it's
funny and I like that this trailer kind
of cuts between the different parts of
the thing bi here we got dog scorpion
again doings in an all of average man
and I loved it like there there are more
looks kind of like just make [ __ ] up
they just kind of push it together
because they're like a terrorist
organization yeah kind of like that's
one of the route is that they're like
eco-terrorists basically yeah try to us
stop shinners maker reactors divided
necessary flip the unnecessary flip
which again you need to see this it's
straight out of final fantasy 7 it's
like the exact way it is it's cool they
found the really paid homage maybe not
in the battle system but in terms of the
the aesthetic again yeah awesome i love
the logo the depth of the logo and stuff
like that I was recently looking at all
the different logos they were coming up
with when they were making the original
game and oh yeah I don't own this and
yes there's a cool um going back there
there was one flash that I I remember
seeing that's right here so this right
here is really interesting you know what
edges edge is especially you don't know
any mess before I know but no oh yes
this different yet ng is actually the
city that advent children takes place ok
now it was kind of built after Midgard
no that was you know our IP and all that
stuff interesting i wouldn't know I've
thats actually make our so what's
interesting about this is that's enough
a children thing so they're gonna I mean
there it seems like they're going to mix
things up right a little bit in terms of
the story because it says here in the
same translation will the story be
adjusted at all the morris as an
addition quote addition to delegated
these episodes more deeply we're
preparing a number of mechanisms and
such to those who play the original
version will know the important parts
and understand the story from the
beginning of the end also for these
people i hope they can be surprised once
again and so that's the thing is you
know there's
was the whole compilation of all fantasy
7 thing with George of service and a
crisis core and all the other random
things and obviously I've been children
right so it's interesting to see maybe
they'll add some some elements of that
or maybe we'll even play through maybe
the game will go beyond be at the end of
the game of even before the tool I think
this is definitely a shout to just the
Expanded Universe for now and that this
is not cool i'm happy brake line the
train line map whatever like edgy on any
train um yeah so there's little nods i
mean the flowers on the ground too i'm
just being exactly so yeah it's cool
that we never see tifa we obviously
don't sierra if we don't see sephiroth
which is great yeah we don't see the
Turks we don't see like yeah any
anything but about getting you an
avalanche yeah you're really sighs I
don't you know yeah from the beginning I
know materia I think that's the one they
want they knew what they were doing by
showing that battle system and I think
it's nice that will have to wait to see
what they come up with later I'm excited
I'm pessimistic about the battling
optimistic about everything else
pessimistic also about the episodic
releases what you didn't get into it's
not really important for this trailer
but this will be released episodically
and we don't know anything about how or
when that's gonna happen hmm so Tim I
think that's it yeah uh thank you for
joining us remember keep it tuned here
for more of the trailer breakdowns right
here on gamespot and we are kind of
funny how long time we'll see you later
bye
you